Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Irina Zhandarova
Ringrazio il pubblico per essere qui,
e sono onorato di aprire
i lavori di TEDxBologna 2011
mostrando una straordinaria invenzione
dello scienziato
più ingiustamente censurato
dai libri di scienza.
Si tratta di Nikola Tesla,
l'autore di più di 700 brevetti
che hanno rivoluzionato il mondo.
Pochi sanno infatti
che l'invenzione della radio
è stata opera sua,
prima di Guglielmo Marconi.
Il marchese italiano
si limitò a utilizzare ben 17
dei suoi brevetti
sulla telegrafia senza fili,
per vedersi attribuire il premio Nobel,
e ciò è dimostrato
oltre ogni ragionevole dubbio
dal fatto che ci sono le date
di registrazione delle sue patenti,
e una sentenza della Corte
Suprema Americana del 1943.
Comunemente, si ignora persino
il fatto che fu lui,
e non Thomas Alva Edison,
a rendere sfruttabile l'energia
nella forma della corrente alternata
che oggi viene utilizzata
dall'industria e dalle nostre
abitazioni civili.
Quando Tesla si recò in America, infatti,
Edison aveva ancora il monopolio
sulla tecnologia elettrica.
Ma tutti i suoi brevetti
erano sulla corrente continua
(il tipo, la forma di energia che oggi
viene utilizzata comunemente
per le batterie)
e quindi non idonea per essere
trasferita sulle lunghe distanze.
Tesla quindi, per poter far
emergere la sua tecnologia,
dovette ingaggiare
un confronto molto serrato,
un confronto commerciale contro Edison.
Alle sue spalle c'era
il magnate Westinghouse, e Edison,
per cercare di difendere le proprie
royalty sulla corrente continua,
e impedire l'avanzamento
della nuova tecnologia,
tentò di demonizzarne
la pericolosità in pubblico.
Per farlo, concepì e realizzò
la prima sedia elettrica del mondo,
e la regalò allo stato di New York,
che la utilizzò per
le sue prime esecuzioni,
e organizzò inoltre delle manifestazioni
sulla pubblica piazza,
di fronte agli organi di informazione,
dove folgorò animali
di piccola e grossa taglia,
come l'elefantessa Topsy
che vediamo in queste clip storiche.
Alla fine, però, prevalse
la tecnologia a corrente alternata
che vediamo in funzione qui dentro
(qui abbiamo i sistemi
polifase di Nikola Tesla)
e i sistemi moderni che
funzionano tutti con un motore
a campo magnetico rotante.
Illuminò la fiera di Chicago
Internazionale del 1893,
e da allora
la corrente elettrica alternata
si è imposta come tecnologia dominante.
Le invenzioni di Tesla spaziano
dalle prime porte logiche dei PC
alla robotica, alla tecnologia
radar, ai raggi X,
agli aerei a decollo verticale,
ai superconduttori,
alla trasmissione di energia senza fili,
e anche alla prima
centrale idroelettrica del mondo
a funzionamento a corrente alternata,
che sarà realizzata
per alimentare la città di Buffalo
sulle cascate del Niagara,
dove infatti vediamo la sua statua.
Nel 1898, di fronte al pubblico allibito
del Madison Square Garden di New York,
Tesla mostrò il funzionamento
di un vascello interamente robotizzato,
radiocomandato, che poteva
eseguire qualsiasi tipo di manovra,
quindi virare a destra,
a sinistra, avanti, indietro,
immergersi, riemergere,
far lampeggiare delle luci
e addirittura farsi esplodere.
Ma non è tutto.
Nikola Tesla, già a fine '800,
aveva una conoscenza della fisica
talmente avanzata che,
conoscendo la natura
oscillatoria della materia,
e quindi che ogni atomo
ha una sua frequenza di risonanza,
mise a punto una scienza,
che lui denominò telegeodinamica,
con la quale era in grado di provocare,
alterando la normale frequenza
di vibrazione degli atomi,
la rottura di qualsiasi materiale,
anche il più duro (come il ferro)
o addirittura provocare sismi artificiali,
come possiamo vedere
nella seguente clip di History Channel.
(Speaker): Sebbene molte
delle invenzioni di Tesla
abbiano effettivamente dimostrato
di approntare vantaggi al genere umano,
la sua visionarietà si è anche
spinta in territori oscuri,
con scopi spaventosi
e ben più distruttivi.
Una delle forze naturali
più potenti sono i terremoti.
Supponiamo che questa forza
possa essere imbrigliata e resa un'arma.
Secondo alcuni, Tesla sa come fare.
La tecnica della telegeodinamica
si basa su un oscillatore meccanico:
un dispositivo, cioè,
in grado di produrre vibrazioni
per entrare in risonanza con diversi
tipi di strutture e materiali.
L'oscilatore meccanico
si basa sul principio
secondo il quale ogni materiale
ha una propria frequenza di risonanza.
Se tale frequenza viene amplificata
da una fonte esterna,
come un oscillatore,
qualunque tipo di materiale
può essere scosso
fino ad un punto di rottura.
La distruzione del Tacoma
Narrows Bridge di Washington, del 1940,
dimostra questo principio.
I venti colpiscono violentemente
il ponte con la giusta frequenza,
provocando così la forte
oscillazione della struttura d'acciaio
secondo un preciso schema ritmico,
che alla fine la distrugge.
Durante le mie ricerche sulla
scienza soppressa, quindi,
non potevo non imbattermi
nella sua ingombrante figura.
Più mi scervellavo per cercare di capire
come fosse stata possibile
una simile amnesia storica,
e più mi convincevo del fatto
che non poteva trattarsi di un caso.
Sentii quindi il forte desiderio
di provare a mettere alla prova
i suoi brevetti sulla
trasmissione di energia senza fili,
che molti autori descrivevano
come mera leggenda.
E ovviamente non disponevo
di un laboratorio attrezzato,
così iniziai a fare
esperimenti casalinghi,
sul tavolo della cucina o del salone.
Spesso avevo come primo compagno
l'odore di bruciato
dei materiali isolanti
sottoposti allo stress,
lo shock dell'alta tensione.
A volte mi capitava persino
di percepirlo nell'insalata
o nel ragù di mia moglie, che oggi
è qui, seduta in mezzo a noi.
Alla fine, però, riuscii a far accendere
una lampada a distanza,
proprio come descritto
da Nikola Tesla nei suoi brevetti.
Una lampada a filamento, da 100W,
brillava alimentata
esclusivamente da un'antenna.
Mi venne il dubbio su come, appunto,
fosse stata possibile
una simile amnesia storica,
e scoprii che a minarne
la credibilità scientifica
era stata la lobby dell'alta finanza,
per motivi di interesse economico.
E, in particolare,
del suo ex socio d'affari,
il banchiere Jean Pierpoint Morgan.
Quest'ultimo, infatti, era contrario
alla tecnologia della trasmissione
dell'energia senza fili
perché preferiva continuare a vendere
i costosi cavi di rame
necessari per i tralicci tradizionali
e soprattutto a controllare
il mercato dell'energia elettrica,
e misurarne i consumi collegando
un contatore a ciascun elettrodotto.
Se, infatti, lo scienziato fosse riuscito
a completare il suo progetto
e a renderlo commerciale - una torre
che stava costruendo a Wardencliffe
nel Long Island, NY, alta 47 mt. -
se fosse riuscito il completamento,
almeno secondo le dichiarazioni
dello scienziato,
egli sarebbe riuscito
a trasferire energia via terra
con una tecnologia rivoluzionaria,
che utilizzava le onde stazionarie
artificialmente prodotte,
e la Terra come
magazzino elastico elettrico.
Con questa tecnologia
intendeva trasferirla
in ogni polo del globo senza dispersione,
e sarebbe stata possibile
riceverla da chiunque, liberamente,
semplicemente piantando
un'antenna in giardino.
Le cose non andarono così:
Morgan bloccò i finanziamenti necessari,
appunto, al completamento della
torre, e diffuse la voce che il genio
era diventato improvisamente folle.
Ciò a dispetto del fatto
che Nikola Tesla era
la quintessenza delle doti intellettive:
parlava correntemente nove lingue,
conosceva praticamente a memoria
tutta la letteratura mondiale,
cosa più unica che rara, per un fisico,
e soprattutto concepiva
le proprie invenzioni
passando direttamente dall'idea
al suo perfezionamento
in ogni minimo dettaglio nella mente.
Quindi dall'idea al prodotto finito,
senza aver bisogno della cosiddetta
fase sperimentale dei prototipi.
Se il suo progetto fosse andato
quindi a buon fine,
probabilmente oggi non saremmo
più circondati dai cavi
che caratterizzano le metropoli
moderne e sarebbero andati
in pensione anche i depositi
tossici delle batterie esauste.
A causa delle voci diffuse da Morgan,
Tesla venne ritenuto folle
e la tecnologia della trasmissione
dell'energia senza fili
finì in oblio prima
della morte stessa dello scienziato.
O almeno, così è stato fino al 2007,
quando i ricercatori del M.I.T.,
l'Istituto Tecnologico Americano
del Massachusetts,
in una conferenza stampa
internazionale dichiararono
di essere riusciti a trasferire energia
fino a distanze di 2 metri e 13
utilizzando un generatore da 400W
per accendere una lampada da 60W.
Per chi non conosceva
la storia di Nikola Tesla,
apparve come un miracolo della scienza.
Ma in realtà non era altro
che una riproposizione grossolana
dei brevetti depositati
da Tesla a fine '800.
Come funziona Witricity? Subito dopo
il clamoroso annuncio,
nacque la Witricity Corporation,
una società
che sta immettendo sul mercato
una nuova generazione
di dispositivi elettrici che anziché avere
il tradizionale cavo
di alimentazione con la spina,
o il vano batterie,
ricevono energia direttamente
da una semplice antenna.
Il funzionamento di questi
sistemi, spiegò Tesla,
è il seguente:
quando due circuiti elettrici
oscillano alla stessa
frequenza di risonanza,
questi possono risonare anche a distanza
senza che tra di essi
vi sia alcun collegamento fisico.
Se quindi abbiamo
un trasmettitore, un circuito oscillante
che alimentiamo elettricamente
per produrre vibrazioni elettriche,
queste tenderanno a propagarsi
a tutti gli altri
circuiti elettrici oscillanti
che risuonano alla stessa
frequenza di risonanza.
Questo, di fatto, significa
trasmissione di energia senza fili,
ed è un principio già noto
in ambito musicale,
dove sostanzialmente
valgono le stesse regole.
Esistono infatti degli strumenti
a corda tradizionale,
come la viola di Bordone,
dove abbiamo un doppio ordine di corde;
il primo viene meccanicamente
fatto vibrare dall'operatore,
mentre il secondo ordine di orde
vibra per simpatia,
ovvero entrando in risonanza
con le onde sonore emesse dal primo.
Ora, oggi vedremo, cercheremo
di battere il record del M.I.T.
utilizzando un sistema Tesla,
quindi trasferendo energia senza fili
fino a una distanza di 3 metri,
anziché 2 metri e 13,
per alimentare una lampada da 50W
con un generatore da 400.
Poi faremo la stessa cosa
a distanza ravvicinata di 1 metro e 20,
per accendere però questa volta
una lampada alogena da 400W,
e vedere come a breve distanza ciò possa
avvenire praticamente senza dispersione,
quasi come vi fosse un cavo di rame.
Tale tipo di tecnologia potrebbe
già trovare applicazione,
per esempio, per quanto riguarda
le macchine elettriche
di nuova concezione,
ovvero quelle che sono equipaggiate
non con batterie chimiche ma semplicemente
con degli ultracondensatori
di ultima generazione
che garantiscono una ricarica
quasi istantanea, in pochi minuti.
Ciò è stato fatto ad esempio
dalla Lotus, che con la sua concept car,
la Zap-X, un'autovettura elettrica
che si ricarica in soli 8 minuti,
che ha un'autonomia di 500 Km,
una velocità di punta di 250 Km/h
e una potenza di più di 600 CV.
Il sistema del M.I.T., a differenza
di quello che vedremo oggi,
utilizza una bobina di rame
per produrre un campo magnetico
che si propaga
su una seconda bobina ricevente,
che la riconverte in corrente elettrica.
Ora concludo passando
direttamente all'esperimento,
perché il tempo stringe.
(Applausi)
Grazie al pubblico, passo...
Adesso 400W, dispersione insignificante.
(Applausi)
Grazie. Possiamo fare la stessa cosa,
io adesso ho utilizzato —
allora questa è la bobina,
il circuito trasmittente,
qui abbiamo un circuito ricevente.
Chi vede il cavo può pensare
che sia collegato,
e dire: ma come senza fili?
Ma in realtà questa è una messa a terra,
perché l'unica cosa che occorre
è una messa a terra buona.
Per ottenere queste prestazioni
e battere il record
mi serviva la messa a terra
ottima dello stabile.
Ma la stessa cosa può essere fatta
con un vaso di terra tradizionale,
ovviamente con prestazioni inferiori
data la quantità di terra
di cui disponiamo.
Signore e signori,
la corrente-da-un'antenna
-in-giardino di Nikola Tesla.
(Applausi)
Andrea Pauri: Grazie Marco, complimenti.